Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel I brought my wife and kids here
to the swamps in Louisiana because we're
catching and cooking anything that moves
we're spearing fish eating frogs fishing
for sharks swimming with alligators
getting hit in the face by fish my
wife's getting way out of her comfort
zone so come along for the ride it's
gonna be a good time
[Music]
gently to the silent trees
I won't forget
you know the secrets of them I breathe
[Music]
well guys Welcome to The Big Easy we're
in New Orleans Louisiana yeah turn up
that AC
ID Nathan is it hot
the boys have definitely gotten used to
Alaskan weather
foreign
here's the hotel we're gonna try to find
some parking
we're in the hotel parking garage and
there are rats everywhere
like the size of my face
were those the biggest rats you've ever
seen yes they're like that big ah okay
get your shoes on we're gonna grab some
dinner
we're gonna get some Cajun food look at
that the alligator pool boy sandwich
check it out we got alligator nuggets
Fried Green Tomatoes crawfish hush
puppies and mozzarella cheese sticks
oh the sandwiches over here oh my
goodness look at that Tommy you still
like alligator yes
all right you guys ready
but look there's another rat
ings
that whole dumpster was making scurrying
noises
we all got some much needed rest last
night we slept in until 10 A.M oh it
felt good we got a few hours before
Cajun experience and I've got a little
boy who's dying to go to a museum Tommy
where do you want to go a World War II
museum
look at that yeah they got a samurai
sword no it's a tight 96. see that
that's a Japanese mortar tube
see that that's a bazooka this is the
German
s
there's a Sherman we drove one of those
[Music]
I think that's the Liberator but I could
be wrong
well that wasn't a bad way to kill an
hour or two
watermelons are so expensive in Alaska
I'm just getting a ton of these
good with them
oh yeah
hi I got snacks watermelons were only
four bucks I got three huge watermelons
these are bronze grapes never even heard
of bronze grapes
they're like plums almost
next few days me and the family are
gonna be exploring the Bayou with Cajun
experience
hi
yeah it's going well you must USB
Stafford's number two they're called
mcdilla Hey Dilla now this is my fourth
time doing this with Cajun experience
the first time was six years ago was
just me and Tommy we had so much fun we
had to come back and bring Nathan so
then we had to come back a third time
with Jacob now it's mom's turn all right
well babe welcome to the Bayou
well see she's real I told you my wife
was real are you really his wife
for real yeah
Miss Becca
there you go nice to meet you I'm
Stafford nice to meet you
better than I deserve give me the tour
babe all right so this whole facility is
three floating houseboats all connected
together and it's awesome look at that
air conditioning feels so good
yeah it is a nice little bunk bed here
this right here is the houseboat where
we come and eat and it's kind of the
common area
is where Stafford and the guides live
whole camp set up right here in the
bayou look at that
I brought you some fishing rods man that
was the last one oh it's been great
let's do the same series I run I run up
in Virginia I got two spinning and two
big casters you want to do some fishing
yeah okay all right I think I saw some
rods over there by the guest cabinets
let's see oh yeah this looks good this
looks promising and it's rigged up wait
the blue one that little bottom rig with
a piece of shrimp
all metal
one of the things we just love about
coming here is you can just do whatever
you want and really play it by ear so
we're just gonna throw some fishing rods
out and see if we can't catch some fish
from the dock and then we're gonna go
throw out some jug lines fish for gar 30
degree weather yeah I bet come let's
take a seed look at this we got a nice
umbrella in the shade we've got fishing
rods got snacks this is nice oh
you know we got the mandas on your head
there you go I got them off
I'll put in
me just don't be nice to him okay
didn't mean to reel up these fishing
rods
okay let's read up reel up the rods to
get the boat in
this trip just got
you know Becca this is my favorite part
just driving around
guys
wonderful
alligator over there
oh that was a big one
saw some really big Asian carp jumping
out of the water
that big alligator right there
there he goes all right guys we're gonna
throw out some jug lines for alligator
gar alligator gar or a massive
prehistoric fish they can get up to nine
feet long pull the tail lamp just like
that boom let's take it right here no we
don't want to do all right that's what
we caught that big one last week 130
pounds seven foot almost seven foot one
go ahead drop that
good job
that's why we call it jug lining you
attach your fishing line to a big
visible jug let it sit for several hours
you come back find your jug and
hopefully there's a fish attached
throw it out throw it out babe
there you go there you go
I hit Fortress
oh my God
big old Asian carp jumped in and hit the
wall right here right behind Dylan tried
to kill him
so I did those are Asian carp they were
imported to help at sewer treatment
plants and when the Mississippi flooded
they escaped now up and down the
Mississippi there's tons of them
oh
that's why we got these Gates on the
boat to protect people
we're gonna go check a crab pot yeah
we're just gonna pass by today we're
gonna run them tomorrow me
me
oh you grab that line too everyone grab
the line everyone grab the Rope so
anywhere you can I think it's the
fastest
let's see what we got oh look they
didn't they didn't took most of that
bait they just throw back in yeah
hungry our crab pots are getting cleaned
out I think we need to go get some more
bait
all right I think we're gonna go throw
the cast net and try to catch some bait
this is what me and Becca call a pro
level move uh we slipped over to
Stafford's boat and left all the kids
with Dylan we don't need bait let's just
go uh let's go hit a restaurant or
something
oh
yeah oh by now oh yeah oh look at this
oh we have something yeah
zero heads up
[Music]
the best but there goes a big club right
there
yeah I think so yeah that's a mullet or
no garbage yeah you got a car you
chopped down on it no he just all
up here these are the ones that hurt let
me get you here
little baby spotted guy right there
look at that there's a little tiny guy
hey look at that look at teeth on nails
so imagine this guy right here some Polo
130 pounds
look at that is that cool
yeah oh look at this we got two Buffalo
and a catfish
we're not supposed to catch those with
cast Nets
there you go this this right here is a
smallmouth Buffalo native species
related to a sucker fish but we'll keep
them for bait right
oh yeah I got him
guess what I've ever thought that's huge
so this is an Asian big head carp these
are the fish that were jumping and
smirking the boat they're a big Plankton
feeder they don't have any teeth they
swim around scoop it up a little
microscopic insects and eating them they
don't have any natural Predators here so
they're just absolutely going crazy in
the ecosystem and pretty much anytime
you can kill them they tell people tell
you to kill one look at that guys what
do you think of that caught them in the
cast yet oh he pooped on me oh I'm a dad
of three boys hey my first rodeo getting
pooped on
well that was fun but we got a gill net
soaking over here we're gonna pull that
up see what's in it
let go of the net let go of the net
you want me to just grab the stick yeah
you got one
oh Asian carp jumped in the boat with
him with a fish the size of a salmon
volunteers go home with you that's
pretty cool
look at that there's one down in there
mine
that's mine Jake I think you might end
up catching the most fish today
three fish four
oh look at that these are fat gizzard
shed
now these are gizzard Chad and they're a
bait fish not that good to eat though I
did try it one time
look at that that right there is a big
gizzard shad
es Dylan and the boys are working the
other end of the net oh those are
monsters
size of that thing they've ever seen one
that big in Virginia
watch out we're gonna Ram oh don't throw
a kid up hit it really good
it is it you gotta come sit down buddy
color
did you see those lillipop flowers they
were like this big and the lily pads are
like this big
hey Dixie
whoa jambalaya and some beans nice white
beans oh white beans nice booty balls
oh
thank you very much sir oh their smoke
guard is so good hey come on we're gonna
get some dinner
you ready to eat some dinner we're gonna
eat Cajun food
oh good huh yeah it does
this Cajun food is good and it sticks
your ribs Tom you like the boudin balls
yeah you think mommy you like the food
and balls are the best
all right who wants some dessert
here we go there's a frozen yogurt or a
moon pie oh a nice cold frozen yogurt
that tastes pretty good well now that
the sun's set and we've got some dinner
I think it's time to go get some frogs
put it on top of it hold it on the
ground
until that frog jumps to the back end
when he jumps to the back end you pull
the string and you bring them on back to
Becca are you ready to catch and eat
some bullfrogs
yeah I'm ready so the water level's a
little wonky and it's going to make
things a bit tricky but what we're gonna
do is drive around and use our headlamps
to try to look for frog eyes glowing in
the dark and once we see a pair of frog
guys we're gonna try to get the boat up
close and catch them even with her hands
or with a long net on a pole these are
the headlamps we use and they're really
bright when you shine them on the frogs
you see their eyes glow in the dark frog
eyes glow whitish blue alligator eyes
are kind of orangish red spider eyes are
blue but they kind of Twinkle and
they're smaller oh yes that's right I
said spider eyes the spiders here are so
big that you can see their eyes glowing
in the dark oh there's one right there
all you can see is legs he's a big boy
look there is an enormous spider on that
Cypress knee I could see his eyes from
like 100 feet away
yeah look at the size of that guy
Folk
[Music]
I can put him in the palm of my hand and
his legs would stick out
Riders out here as they can run across
the top of the water and they bounce
okay let's call out frogs rather than
spiders
[Music]
let's look at over here but I saw it
from a weird angle all right back up up
here we're gonna get you one we saw we
saw one okay see you he's right down
there okay babe yeah
oh it's huge
[Music]
oh
I've loved it zombie good spot good spot
[Music]
you look at it oh he's just straight he
made a squeaky noise here
hear it
yeah yeah I got a little peepers
I thought he spotted him
oh is that him right there I see him I
do see him oh he's a big boy
[Music]
what are you calling your tree frogs yes
Jeff's so they're all named Jeff we got
Jeff Jeff and Jeff we got three little
Jeff
oh he is cool
oh there's a big one right over there
Mama this one might be good for you
he's
really close
Get It Go in
he wandered off
oh there he is right there there he goes
he's behind you behind you look
yeah when it comes to tiny frogs we are
rocking it right here we're moving in
the headliner oh I see him yeah
there's a big Cypress music
oh
yeah
yeah look look there's a little frog
yeah he's on oh he's home
[Music]
I'm really struggling to get the boys
caring about bullfrogs when there's all
these cute little peepee toads running
around this this is this is fun isn't it
yeah I see if see see the white eyes how
white they are
oh
all right Nathan you gonna get him
whoa
oh here he is
I got him
yay
that's that's Jeffrey
the wedge in there there we go
there you go that's not a bad one he's
not huge but he's proper he's like
riding and it was it on this side yeah
right in there oh
he just moved
you see him you see him right there give
me that give me that
okay
yeah
got it you got him yeah we got him I got
it let me see
it I got him
that was an excellent team effort got
yourself okay
I have a death now do you have a frog in
your house yes
he's not in my ear in my hair anymore so
I'll take it
remember
get him get closer
yeah
you guys did you put Jeff on Mommy no
you're so brave
okay next okay I guess
oh look at this there's a baby alligator
[Music]
is that cute
Asian carp just jumped in my lap
oh
well I'll tell you what we're having a
great time but it's about midnight so I
think it's time to get the kids to bed
Jake what is that it's a Jeff on the
stick
oh you got a frog on your face I think
the kids ended up being more interested
in the tree frogs and the bullfrogs but
that's why we're out here to have fun
hey Dixie dog
some water so
what happened did he Dixie eat your frog
what oh pixie oh Dixie Dixie eight oh oh
Dixie the dog just ate Jacob's frog
Dixie the dog didn't know better she
just a dog
oh boy
so we've got a full day of Adventure
planned tomorrow and it's going to be
hot so I filled this camel pack 80 up
with water and I'm gonna freeze it
all right Tom you got yourself in bed
maybe you like the top bunk good well
it's a little past midnight we gotta get
these kids to bed I'm gonna put the
camera down see you guys in the morning
oh
I figure I got a couple fishing rods
I'll throw them off the docks and let
them soak while the kids get ready for
breakfast
there's a fish on
very good there we go
got a little Buffalo
oh my goodness oh gravy Nathan's gonna
love this favorite thing in the world is
biscuits and gravy oh okay
hey Dixie dog what are you doing down
there let me rub
Jacob have you forgiven Dixie
not quite yet okay oh a good breakfast
oh here we go
got the icy cold camel pack that's been
in the fridge
yeah there we go
you like that love it it's really nice
first thing we're doing today is
checking those guard jugs we set out
yesterday you see this one's drifted
over to the lilies might have a fish on
it might not all right don't wrap your
hand around the Rope okay
it's a long
there we go we're gonna throw that back
out there another one of our jugs up
there
make sure you don't wrap your hand okay
oh he took everything
we'll keep that one on there man yes
yeah it is pretty chewed up he bit it
and ran with it for a little while and
probably spit it back out or something
something happened
well a few of those jug lines got messed
with so we're gonna throw back in let
them soak for the rest of the day
well we went downstream a little ways
and we're about 45 minutes from the Gulf
of Mexico and we're gonna fish for
sharks
you know in order to bring the sharks in
we got to Chum the water really good so
we're having the kids swim around a bit
Splash bars if any of you guys got a
scab you need to pick that's cool too
Becca you like the backpack I love the
backpack
yeah
let's use the bait knife
Justin you want a piece of this natural
water you would die
give you oh my you have a piece worthy
of a woman who birthed three boys
watermelon isn't it
for a fishing rod to Twitch
foreign
there you go
oh look at that you jumped yeah Jake
Jake's keeping you from dying
oh
[Music]
look at that he Almost Got Away there
you go Tom kill me you like that oh
nice look at that little shark huh yeah
they got really rough skin it's like
sandpaper here let's get it back in the
watermelon
Jacob eat watermelon
he's angry he might nibble your toes
I'm gonna pull out our lunch and get it
heated up
[Music]
red beans and pork sausage honey chicken
rice bowl and black pepper steak and
Asian Bowl here well it's 93 degrees
we'll put those out in the sun let those
warm up a little bit
sit on a sandbar painting yeah letting
the kids be crazy and eating watermelon
catching sharks is not too bad Mark here
guys
don't horse them just take it nice and
slow
fun fact baby shark is called a pup so
that's a little pup okay
yeah should we send them back
are you guys hungry you want some proper
lunch beans and rice
oh look at that it's a nice little
painting it's the boys how do how the
camel pack you like the cold camel pack
it's so cold I'm I'm cuddling it it's
nice
come on boys boats leaving
did you have fun
we're gonna pull some of those crab pots
see if we can't get some big tasty crabs
for dinner
you grab that whole thing see them in
there we got some crabbies
now I noticed your traps are purple and
yellow is that is that because you guys
are big Alabama fans oh man
oh let's see what we got here oh I can
see one
aggressive get him Nate get him get him
oh a little mail little I think you got
it yeah
look at that that is a big boy that's
the biggest one
there you go oh I can see I can see a
big boy in there
well not a ton of crabs but there's some
Big Boys in there that'll taste good
well back here at the camp and we're
just killing some time before dinner
there you go good job good little extra
stuff
oh looks like Stanford's got some crabs
oh geez
oh yeah you got a flounder
is that a crap trap yeah
look at that teeth on that thing yeah
those are tasty are really tasty okay
oh
my God
you guys you guys are swimming an
alligator infested waters
watch out for alligators Tommy
[Music]
we didn't quite catch enough frogs to
make a meal out of them so we're gonna
go ahead and let these two frogs we
caught last night go luckily Stafford's
got a bunch of Frozen frog legs so we're
gonna still have some Nathan who wants
to swim with the Frog
you ready
yeah yo go swim with them just be gentle
you ready hold on
you wanna um frog
yeah here you go frog
gy he's chasing you
there's an alligator longer than me that
just went swimming over there
boys don't seem too bothered by it
thank you
boys just hopped out of the water and
there's an alligator right there he's
just right there
we got boiled blue crab we got potatoes
and weenies we got some deep fried frog
legs of course a bunch of watermelon
oh my goodness wow
Jeff you gotta have a frog leg babe I'll
I'll try one I'll take one
there we go three little things Jake do
you like those frog legs those are good
guys you ready a third frog leg yeah
those are good who wants ice cream me
oh thank you very much
you got school you like that baby is
that good oh good I love it
well we got a belly full of food and the
sun has set it is time to go spear some
fish we're gonna go try to catch a bunch
of fish for crab bait and this is one of
my favorite things to do here in
Louisiana
all right Becky you ready
[Music]
Tommy fish left are you okay bud
today it tastes like you hurt you heard
look at all the fish slime on the rail
right here yeah
yeah there's so many bugs they got this
big fan to blow them off us let's go
come on Mama
drive along real slow in the clear
shallow water and you'll see fish
swimming around and you come down and
throw the spear at them now that's
pretty cute you got a bomb it with their
three boys up there poking fish
yeah you'll get them oh Becca get him
you know your night is so
cool
it is Becca you're a guard Slayer oh
yay
[Music]
there you go
there we go
I got it got it
you ready there we go
there we go
thank you
all right we'll see you in the morning
foreign
guys I've been shooting these Outdoor
Adventure videos for 10 years now and
when people ask me my number one
recommendation it's Cajun experience
this place is so much fun and it's so
unique and it's family friendly and it's
so affordable to put it in perspective
coming here with my family of five for
two days costs the same as one eight
hour offshore fishing charter as always
guys I'll put a link in the video
description below if you want to come
here and try this as well I think
Stafford's got some breakfast for us
oh is this breakfast
oh beignets
oh Beignets are the best they're Cajun
Donuts
oh they're still warm
hey Jacob
do you know what these are
you look what I've got oh my is that
what I think it is that's a beignet oh
my oh this is over here everybody wants
Beignets get pants on and come outside
yummy
oh that rain's coming yeah we're
starting to get rained on
and it's just like that the rain cleared
up
gotta love these little summer rain
storms
but she's a good actress isn't she very
good actor yeah thank you always
y'all be good
[Music]
all right here I'll pull the car up
oh
we're just hiding out under the Pavilion
and I think the rain finally eased up
wow that's the biggest grasshopper I've
ever seen it's a grasshopper oh look
it's going straight for your your
jugular
a good old Dylan and Justin they've been
fun now Becca I know you normally don't
like catching frogs and running around
in swamps but was it fun it was fun I
had a good time you know the bite is
beautiful even at night it's really
pretty well we're slightly soggy but I
think it's time to start heading our way
back to New Orleans
[Music]
oh oh it is late and I am so tired but
we had such a great time filming this
video we hope you guys enjoyed watching
it too and if you guys like these types
of videos make sure to click subscribe
and we'll see you guys next video If you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button and you'll get notifications
thanks for watching